(crowd cheering)
- I like your nails.
- I know.
- Your nail color is cool.
- Thank you.
I went gold.
- Yeah. I love the gold.
- Thank you.
I was going gold.
Yeah. I was trying to feel cool.
- I gave up feeling cool.
Years ago.
- I was trying to match this.
I was trying to match my
stylist does cool outfits
for me on this other show
and I was just like, yeah,
I'm just trying to be cool
like her.
So wait, what's your
mother's day like for you?
- It's always fun.
It's always silly.
My son Cooper is now 21.
- Oh my God.
Oh yeah.
College, yeah.
- He's in college.
He's a, there he is ignoring me
- Ignoring. That's like out
to dinner with the kids.
- Yeah.
- That's what that looks like now.
But do you still get actual words?
I get things like "K."
- Oh no.
See, this is why I get words
is like, my daughter just
learned how to like
start making sentences.
She's seven.
So she now knows how to text
and she, all I get is like
it'll be like, "I" period,
"love" period, "you"
she's like figuring it out.
- Yeah
- So it's like sometimes
like reading hieroglyphics
like cause you're like,
what is she saying,
you think?
- By the way, just be happy
you're getting words.
- [Clarkson] No, I know I know
- Cause I get emojis and letters, but we
- [Clarkson] Emojis?
- Oh yeah, come on.
That's how I know he
is alive half the time.
I've taken to sending
him stuff on Instagram.
Just so I get like the
thumbs up or the like
so it's like proof of life.
- Oh my gosh.
But you're scaring me cause
like I will not do well
- No
- with that.
- I'm still not doing well.
- Like I'm the friend
that like, when like,
even like my house manager to my house,
I'm like, "Hey well text
me when you get home,
And you're, you know, in your house."
I'm like that person,
like every day my friends
think I'm crazy, but I'm like
I don't want anybody to
turn up a "Dateline" special.
- No
- [Clarkson] like yeah
- I'm the same way.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- And my mother was the same way.
But you were saying
about Mother's Day gifts.
Cooper and I, and it
came from my mother who
a very silly sense of humor.
- Oh, I love it.
- And loved pranks off camera.
Give each other really silly gifts.
Like it's always a mug that says something
like I have one that says
that he got me that says "I'm
a blanking Ray of sunshine."
But I brought one of, one
of my favorite gifts from him for you.
So they, yes
this was actually my
Valentine's day gift this year.
- What is it?
Wait, this is your, Ah! Oh God.
Oh man. Oh man. (crowd
laughing and clapping)
- That, was my Valentine's day gift
from my son.
- I am gonna show my son, this footage.
And he is gonna love you so much.
Cause he tries to scare me all the time
and it's always with spiders.
- Yeah. But by the way, and I got the box
and he kept going, "did
Amazon deliver yet?"
I'm like, "no, no.
He's like, "oh, call
me as soon as they do."
So I'm like, "okay, I'm opening it."
And I do it.
- [Clarkson] I love that.
And I was doing like, why can't I open it?
I did it, I shrieked, I dropped the phone
and then put it on my assistant's desk.
- Yeah. And then you paid it forward
- Okay. So wait, your new
book is all stories inspired
by your mom.
So what made you wanna write it?
I love the title.
- Thank you
- It's awesome.
- Tall tales from a short woman.
- Yes. During COVID I had a
wonderful writing partner.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- And it started out as
an article about, you know
parents lying.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- And then it went to, well,
let's write rewrite the
history of the world on how
my mother would tell it.
- [Clarkson] Yes.
- [Rivers] And then after we
got stuck on Napoleon, on Elba
without a Starbucks,
we decided that we should expand,
- [Clarkson] Oh my God, I
love this writing session.
- Yeah. We decided we would
expand the, the genre.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- Shall we say?
And it just started coming
up with like the goofiest
silliest things and to be able to write
in my mother's voice.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
Allowed me a lot of creative freedom.
Because what are people gonna do?
They, so I had one publisher
say to me, well, it's
you're gonna have legal issues.
I'm like, who are they gonna sue?
I'm the estate like I'm disparaging her.
(crowd applauding)
I, I'm not gonna sue myself.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- But you know
- [Clarkson] And I think it's funny.
Like she would love that.
- Oh my god she would and,
and it allowed me to
sort of just comedically
just take a huge leap.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- And I was allowed to make a lot
of jokes and probably say a lot
of things that I would not get away with.
- [Clarkson] Yes
- But that she would.
- Yes.
- And really sort of also
juxtapose juxta, juxtapose
easy for me to say the two
different types of humor.
- [Clarkson] Yeah.
- Cause I'm much more sarcastic.
- [Clarkson] Yeah. Which I love.
- Me too
- Sarcasm.
- [Rivers] Yeah.
- What is life without it?
Okay. So Melissa's book is called
"Lies My Mother Told Me, Tall
tales From a Short Woman."
It's out right now.